it's time for ej's veto
presented by no one unsullied by
sponsorship
since 1989. thank you dr o'neal you know
what sunday is don't you
no valentine's day oh valentine's day is
sunday
channing knew that the buffet of
goodness knew that for sure
chuckster i have a little valentine's
quiz for you are you game to take a
little valentine's quiz
sure here we go all right there's a few
questions okay
who shoots the arrows causing people to
fall instantly in love
oh man uh cupid
cupid that's right i didn't think i just
thought of that one
go ahead just look at the monitor
wait what's that cap
see we were hoping that this would go on
for
the duration of the quiz and you
wouldn't know that you were
a cat yeah well do you know do you know
who rod ponton is
i do not have you seen that video he's
the attorney
who couldn't get the cat filter off of
his screen i didn't see that when he was
doing a zoom
[Laughter]
in the video settings
you might want to uh uh
we're trying to can you hear
i'm here live that's not i'm not a cat
wait i'm not a cat it disappointed me
chuckster by looking at the monitor that
earlier i was just trying to distract
you with some meaningless questions oh
my god but man
like i see all you know that's hilarious
he's in court and he's gotta look you
can't get the cat filter off
how about this one like this one better
well give me another one
give me something else everybody knows
he's a jackass give me something else
oh those were our two options right
there all right very good i'm great
that was hilarious hey by the way chuck
how many valentine's day cards are sent
worldwide
300 million 1 billion oh sorry
and who's the most famous nba star born
on valentine's day
had his number 32 retired by the detroit
pistons
rip hamilton very good shack very good
shaq
you knew that but you don't know
sunday's valentine's day
at any rate because i don't do dates
ernie okay